we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a caller
so deranged and incoherent I don't know
if they're under the influence of drugs
or alcohol in this phone call
um it is it is Troy York under a fake
name and he seems Furious that I think
well let me just play it it's about
I don't even know what he thinks it's
something related to what I said about
tipping hey David pagman David brookson
yeah hey you're a hypocrite
um Pac-Man you made a video about not
wanting a tip when you go out to a
restaurant and well remember it's not
about not wanting the tip I tip well
Everywhere I Go
it's about I don't like tipping culture
and I would like to restructure it so
that tips aren't expected and people are
paid a living wage apparently it sounds
like you go out to eat a lot like that
the best fine dining restaurants all
right well you know if I want to go out
to eat I'll go out to eat Troy it has no
it's not in your business oh no are you
at a truck fun kid or a hedge fun kid I
am neither I I am a self-made man and uh
but the question is uh Minister packant
um
well the point I want to bring off is
you're always doing anti-trump
um videos
and then you do a video on the service
industry and the restaurants
and how workers should not rely on tips
they should have wages
yeah living wages I I believe you say
and um
well that's what Trump was trying to do
he was trying to bring back good
jobs that the Democrats send overseas to
China right yeah so listen Trump didn't
have any idea how to do that many of
those jobs simply no longer exist and it
has nothing to do with tipping culture
I'm afraid to break it to you and one
time you didn't have so many of these
restaurants in this country there are
way too many restaurants and most of
them are foreign owned globalists
[Music]
they shuffled money laundering and
most of these restaurants should not
exist but only exist because of
globalization all right this is very
crazy I guess Troy what I guess he only
has so-called American food I don't know
it's a very very strange message but
listen I uh for for as long as
restaurant workers
depend on tips I'm going to tip my point
is I would like a different structure
where we have prices the prices include
all fees and then the employees are paid
a living wage that's what I would like
to see we're going to talk about deep
fake technology on the bonus show today
and the role that it might play in the
2024 election we are also going to talk
about Air New Zealand the airline
starting to weigh passengers before they
board international flights and the
impact that this is having and North
Korea's attempt to launch its first spy
satellite
has ended in failure
and it is pretty humiliating all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad I can't
say it much better than that thank you
Alex so I will leave it with you as
please sign up at joinpakman.com get
access to the bonus show otherwise we'll
be back tomorrow with a new show see you
then